Hello folks.
We are live.
So I believe we were just starting to
try to profile a little bit here.
I need to take some time to like go fix
up uh the stream settings and do some
minor things, but I don't know. I've
mostly just wanted to work on this and
that's been
pretty much all I've been doing.
Let's see if we're getting reasonable
numbers out of it.
So 18.6 mil
Okay, this can have
GPU flag.
Yeah, this is making a nice mess of
things, but again, this is throwaway
test.
We're going to do the cleanup day will
be Thursday. I've only got a couple
hours now. And what I'd like to figure
out if I can do, not even really a
couple hours, like maybe an hour, hour
and a half. Uh what I'd like to figure
out if I can do is I'd like to see if we
can at least get some reasonable
profiles
out of this and if uh the drive bend if
we can make it work.
Yeah. So this is fun.
And does this already have Yeah, this
already has the flag. So I already put
this flag in myself. It just needed to
be hooked in.
Uh, we're going to do OM 8192
actually. Well, let's do direct.
Okay. So, what this test is supposed to
do is minimal API overhead. So, this
should be the ceiling of Perf.
Uh, except I'm dumb and I did drive
instead of breakout. So, let's fix that.
Hey, Liberty, welcome.
16.5 is fine. Little bit of cash
overhead.
OM8192.
Uh we'll do this one with one buffer,
one core,
uh 64
and then on CPU
Yeah. See, so that's very close, right?
A tiny bit of threading overhead.
What the heck is this skills thing? It's
just prompts, right?
Yeah, that's what it should be. It's a
little annoying that because this works
with a macro, you have to do it this
way.
I' I'd say that's a little bit annoying.
But
I mean, not really a huge deal.
OMP pragma. Okay.
So, basically what I wanted to see by
doing that,
um,
can I set this to zero and recover full
PF?
There's still the manager thread
overhead
to be fair. It's very small, but it is
there.
Uh, this appears to me to be hanging.
Yeah, because you can still have no
threads multibuffers, I suppose.
Little confusing. Little confusing for
sure. Does this not hang anymore?
Okay, so this does not hang anymore. We
get some reasonable speed out of it.
Yeah. So, okay, we recover a little bit
of the PF. No big deal. Right now, I set
this to four threads.
We get a little over 3x perf. And if I
set this to eight threads,
we get 52.
my double buffer.
It's actually This should be about the
same.
Interestingly, it's not about the same
though.
Okay. 16.
And that's actually worse. What if I do
four?
Worse. Interesting. So, it doesn't scale
past um
eight threads, it seems.
There's a little bit of noise in it. So,
5560 mil
Did we have um a breakout test from Hang
on.
Yeah, we got test performance multi
here, right?
So, actually, this is what I'd like to
do is I'd like to add this into here.
Let's do 8192
with a 5second timeout.
So I there's still this big gap. Let's
figure this out because there shouldn't
be, right?
Hang on. That doesn't How many threads
is that using?
set
uh the hell?
threads.
I need What's the OM call for that? Just
one line right
Okay, now that's eight threads.
Now we can actually get some test
results, right?
There's 120
mil.
So this is 16 mil, right?
Yeah. 16 mil.
And this is frame skip four.
And now we have we have 16 cores.
So the best we see is 120 mil
126 mil. So it doesn't really scale
above um eight cores, but it does scale
above four cores. We see this
130 mil SPS. Okay, so 8192M's 8 cores
equals 130 mil SPS, right?
So we should be able to do one buffer,
eight cores.
was it 16
times was it eight cores 128.
There's probably something weird with
this chip actually. If I'm seeing it
like just stop speeding up after eight
cores,
I wouldn't be surprised.
constellation.c but perfer. So
constellation is still active. This is
uh that's not a canceled project that is
going into puffer 4. Constellation is
dramatically easier than what I'm doing
now to finish. So once I have all of the
training infrastructure finished, I will
basically get to finish constellation
while I also run experiments for 40 for
a few weeks. So that's basically going
to be my chill project uh while I polish
stuff up
because believe it or not, doing your
own logging in viz and stuff in C is
easier than this. [laughter]
It's a lot easier than this.
Also, the name just rocks.
I actually the inspiration for it was
kind of um there are multiple uh ARPGs
that use uh like constellations there.
Actually, there are a bunch of games
that do this. They use like
constellations for their skill trees.
So, I think I was playing Grimdawn and I
probably got it from there. But it's
such a cool concept, you know,
and it makes so much sense for data biz
because, you know, you have all the
stars and you draw the patterns.
Path of Oh, is that a constellation?
That's just a skill tree, right? That's
not like That's just a giant skill tree.
If you look up Grimdons, it is literally
constellations that you fill in and like
you get bonuses for filling in the whole
one, like a whole constellation.
Uh Skyrim also has this, right? Skyrim
skill tree is also constellations.
I think there are another couple games
as well. I'm not thinking of
This is going to just add more throwaway
code. But I mean, we need to isolate
this, right? Like for some reason,
for some reason there's this huge gap
between our version and what should be
possible.
At least it only does it in end speed
test.
just looked up
looked up what?
Oh, the Grimdon one. Yeah, it's a if you
like ARPGs, it's a really really good
one. I played it for a few weeks back. I
always get bored of that genre though.
The only games that ever hold my
interest for a long period of time are
MMOs, like longer than a few weeks.
It's just the best game genre in my view
and it's not close.
[snorts]
I think I've spent longer No, I've
definitely spent longer on individual
bosses or individual pieces of content
in MMOs than I've spent on like any
other game.
But as far as others go, Grimdon was
pretty good.
So, this is still going to run through
the DLL, right?
Yeah, this still runs through the DLL.
That would suck because that would mean
we just straight up can't use DLS.
to update. Is this simple or there a few
things that need to change? There are a
few things that you'll need to change.
It's really not bad though. Um, it's
really not bad.
Like here, I'll put it this way. It's
literally simple enough that you could
have claude do it and not make a mess of
your code, provided you don't have
custom shared in it stuff.
I'm going to make it as minimal as
possible. Link key. Um, this is a huge
update. This is like a truly insane
amount of stuff.
GBA games custom function to my binding
to be able to call it in Python. Got
mgba running in povert. That's awesome,
man. I wish those were just faster.
[laughter]
I just wish they were faster.
The absolute ceiling is always going to
be single core speed times numbum cores,
right?
I mean, still, I think that if we could
get them to at least something
reasonable, we could probably use them.
They're at least one order of magnitude
too slow for current algorithms, though.
At least one.
But hey, who knows? You know, maybe
we'll do some work on like scaling
architecture size or whatever with
Puffer 4. Maybe it'll get better.
I do think that RL you just need samples
though.
Emu sucks and logic is still faster.
You know, at some point maybe I will
take the time to go understand how
emulation works and why it's slow. Um,
this is the type of thing though that I
like I wish I could just give to
somebody to do.
Like is it really I don't know. I'm a
little bit suspicious because emulation
seems like one of those areas where it
probably is well optimized and it's just
slow, but I just don't understand why.
5K. So 10k
ever thought of relooking at world
models? Uh we are relooking at world
models but not in the way that you
expect. We have a collaboration
directly rather than loading in. So,
write is required.
Static build mode. See, but I don't see
how this would be slow.
Uh, we can try this static build, but
like this will probably work.
I'll let it do this because why not?
Just so we have a confirmation. But I'm
pretty sure that we know it's compiler
shenanigans now.
Sure, you can run that. Actually, I'll
let you do that.
All good. Okay. So then this is
literally me not understanding an
important systems thing.
Global offset table
that are dynamically linked
addresses of functions. Interesting.
Okay. So everything gets So everything
gets ind direction.
Okay. I actually need to spend some time
understanding this cuz this is something
I should absolutely know.
Let's isolate.
Okay, that's a good test.
Yeah, that's a good test. If this drops
to
65 mil
then it's in direction but it doesn't.
So there's tiny tiny overhead but that's
like noise
something specific to shared library
aren't getting inlined.
Compiler won't be called externally so
it can inline them. Okay,
it is some to it's totally some compiler
shenanigans
I'm trying to think what then how we can
isolate this.
I'm trying to think what other like it
has to just be like compiler doing
something jank, right? Because it's it's
the compiler doing something jank with
this as a shared object, I would think.
I wish I didn't have to do this as a DL,
but I think we do.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Burning token
simulator.
I mean, for it to be that big of a
difference, it would have to just be
like not in lining anything, right?
I'm going quick here because I just want
to have um I want to have a confirmation
one way or another this morning. Uh, I
don't care about what it's messing up
here. This is all getting chucked
anyways.
Oh, okay. It literally just macroed the
export call. I was wondering what the
heck that was.
Okay, I'm actually way more comfortable
with that then.
So now this one
uh this one should be able to be
like this one should use way less stuff.
So we can just export
everything.
Oh, okay. So, I don't actually need
that.
This shouldn't need cuda anywhere.
Yeah, something is massively screwed up.
It's cuz theo gets compiled with CUDA.
Okay.
that's probably a good bet for what the
problem is. To be fair, that's probably
a very good bet for what the problem is.
Some cuda jank.
I mean, it's compiler something or other
because there's no reason for this.
There's no way that it's that much
slower just for compiling it as a shared
ob
69. Okay. Well, that wasn't it then. Be
right back. Let me use a restroom and uh
we'll keep going on this.
I leave in about an hour.
Trying to think if I want to get myself
a quick mug of tea.
Yeah, I'll be right back, guys. One sec.
Let me get some tea.
Got my tea. Let's get another 45 minutes
in.
Maybe a little more. So,
Let me see.
Break out minimalc.
DL open.
Yeah. Well, this is completely stupid
the way that this test is set up, right?
Yeah. because this is trying to do the
step through the DLL.
much the name of this is just going to
be expose as little as possible, make
opaque as possible, and then see if that
lets us have optimized shared object.
And if not, then we have to figure
something else out.
Right.
Yeah. So, this goes in there now.
Minimal. And then we literally just need
to expose that.
Um,
it's also possible that having the end
exposed is also going to be screwy.
We might even just put the entire thing
in the DL. Something is screwed with
shared ob. Like this is not a real bug.
This is a compiler being screwy thing.
like all this stuff here. This is like
super super basic stuff just being done
faster, right? This is just like, oh
well, let's see if we load uh what if we
export less stuff from the DL. But if we
fold uh this function call in
debug,
it probably still needs ray lib. I think
that this is going to mess up
What are we doing here? Step all
function. Init all function. Okay, so
this is what we want.
Still somehow 61 mil.
So now it's literally just called like
do the entire thing in the shared OB and
then it's purely compiler quirk.
Yeah. So like now this is just going to
go into
Yeah. So this is in the minimal file
here
and then the test is going to become
completely trivial.
This doesn't have
a pick.
So any function could be overridden.
Okay.
Well, we have a whole bunch of things
that we can run through. The idea is
just like we've got a bunch of compiler
flags that we can now just run through
and we have a super fast minimal little
uh minimal little test 77 mil. So that's
faster.
We'll just run through all the flags
basically.
Let's see if this is slower. You know
what?
I wonder if it's just using fewer
threads,
but no, because we're specifying eight
OM. Hang on. What's this?
OM overhead.
just 03
then lol
like Okay, sure.
feature you would have never thought of.
Uh so Peru came up with a different
threading model. Uh it parallelizes
along an axis I wouldn't have thought to
parallelize across because it's kind of
counterintuitive and it's immediately
made stuff better. It's actually what
I'm testing right now. We have a
compiler bug. It's It's better even with
the compiler bug
Try that.
That looks weird to me, but we'll try
it.
So basically I'm just iterating through
right now a bunch of dumb stuff because
we have a compiler quirk where for
whatever reason
um so Puffer is using a shared library
for the new builds and for whatever
reason the multi-threading uh the
multipprocessing back end we're using is
slow in it.
What the heck else can we do with this?
Wait, we tried we tried doing um
We tried doing OM inside and outside of
the shared library, didn't we?
I wonder is this could this just be
something incredibly stupid like a
timing death?
I don't think so.
Maybe that actually is even going to get
us to be faster once we go ahead and do
that.
I guess it was just that my threading
model before sucked.
We can probably do something way
simpler.
I'll let it do this. Sure.
I'd actually prefer not to have the OM
dependency
if we can because um there is a system
package you need for that that's not
default.
Also like sometimes other libraries set
OM num threads and screw stuff up.
Yeah, this is a good test. So if it's if
it's OM specific,
then we might just not bother with OM.
Oh, it's freaking it's OMP.
100% OM. Jeez.
How is it that much slower? It's a
compiler quirk, dude.
Like, I don't know. It's specifically OM
in a shared library being weird.
Or OM with a shared library. It's weird.
Very, very weird.
I mean, we're not tied to OM. I just
used it because it was super quick for
um for testing stuff
and it's like a nice if you're not doing
something weird with a shared library,
it's a really easy way to test like
theoretically how fast should you be
able to thread this thing because it's
very well optimized most of the time.
It also has all these like these nice
chunking behaviors that I kind of will
miss.
No, you can't have
per buffer and stepping worker.
I mean, we can do it initially, I
suppose.
That's awful. Awful design, though.
We'll try this really quick though as a
way to see. Um,
I mean, this design like this is just
stupid.
Like guys, obviously I'm going to have
to play with this a bunch. Um,
and obviously this code sucks,
but this is pretty nice for just
iterating through a whole bunch of
different things because in the last
hour we've basically figured out we've
isolated down the performance gap to uh,
OM plus shared libraries. We said OM is
very very good when not being used with
the shared library
and you can actually with a very simple
threaded implementation you can match OM
That is on GPU though. Wait.
Okay. On CPU
Let's see if we're hitting the same
purop issue.
I mean, I could redesign this to not use
shared libraries at all, I suppose.
But the thing is the compilation.
If I could speed up compilation a ton,
maybe it would be worth it. I don't
think you can though. The thing that's
nice with the shared obs is the instant
compilation time.
cuz like I don't have to hook in a
million things for torch. Come to think
of it, like
you'd still end up doing it this way, I
think, regardless.
What on earth is this?
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, what?
>> Like what?
Why?
Why would you ever do that?
These things just do absolutely insane
[ __ ]
That's too much even for a throwaway
test. Like why would you do that?
Spin weight is super gross though.
I mean, we'll try it.
What was the P thread test from before
doing that was so good?
is this one right?
Well, not atomic load.
It's like the same freaking code, isn't
it?
per worker done flags.
Uh, you shouldn't have to do that. You
should just be able to go match
I'll let it do this, but then after this
we're going to do uh we'll go back to
the minimal one.
We'll make sure that that's actually
giving us the result.
This is But wait, this is But this is
different
And this is called from a shared
library. This is called from the shared
library.
I mean, unless it's something completely
stupid
here. We'll double check.
I mean, it could be that we have the
args wrong, but if this matches the args
we expect.
Yeah. You know, that's exactly what we
expect for uh for breakout.
Yeah. So, I mean to reiterate what we're
doing here, right? Um, we have this new
vectorzation backend that distributes
the computation of different
environments on different cores. That's
all it does. Uh, it's fancy because it
has to be buffered in a couple different
ways, including the transfers to GPU,
but that's not the issue right now. The
pure CPU path right now, we're having
some issues where different backends are
screwy when uh used with shared
libraries or not.
No per iteration sync threads
just run freely and count. We need to
sync steps
any sync pattern
Hang on. The working implementation has
no per thread.
>> Yeah. Okay. So that's why this is like
trivial.
Duh.
I'm pretty sure I'm right here that it's
just purely
something screwy.
I'll follow editing to spare or stand
alone.
I think it literally is just open uh OM
being weird and else not being able to
match it even though it is weird.
Those atomics are a little less
overhead.
And then I don't know about that. Relax.
I also don't know what the heck would be
screwing it up in the shared library.
Like
we could just do everything not in the
shared library, I guess, but that seems
like a really dumb thing to do.
Here
we're going to try this.
I've seen that. That's an old paper tur
turtle. Right.
The thing is they're scaling. It's the
age old trick of X-axis's samples only.
do we have the DLL here?
There's no DLL, right?
Uhuh. There's no DLL.
>> November 2025.
Is that Ben?
This one, right?
Yeah. Ben and Kevin.
Uh where's the x axis?
You see the x-axis is in environment
steps,
right?
So like what is this? This is depth
four, which is probably too small. This
is depth eight.
But then this is now using um eight
times the amount of compute.
the scaling does look good on this, but
this is also um I don't know. This is
kind of a weird problem.
These curves, I don't like the shape of
these curves. Like this seems weird to
me.
I don't I do not believe you need
networks that big.
Okay, fine. Go ahead. Confirm your
baseline.
very very small things changing the perf
a lot
and I got to go in a few minutes as well
because I got to get to the gym.
I'm gonna have to fiddle with this thing
a whole bunch most likely.
I'm going to see if I can do it though
um like later today or whatnot because
I'd like Thursday to not be fiddling
with stuff. I'd like Thursday to be
clean up puffer lip.
Ooh.
Uh, that's interesting.
I could have sworn I checked that. That
was No, you know what? This is the only
This is the one place I didn't check
that I was using the right clock. H
I would think it would still be close
though. That would be weird.
This is the last thing we're doing and
then I got to get ready and I got to run
to the gym.
Apparently, I set it on auto mode at
some point, which like I fat fingered
the key. It should not be on auto mode.
Figured I'd disable that. Nope. It's
still fast, though.
So, I did not mess up. In fact, if
anything, it's better now.
Okay, crazy compiler differences. I
don't know. We'll figure this out later.
I got to go get to the gym. Um, I have a
whole bunch of appointments and things
to do later today. I may be streaming a
bit in the evening. We will see. I do
want to get this done today. Uh, if
you're interested in my work generally,
I stream all my dev feed this puffer a
star on GitHub. It's free. It helps me
out a ton. We're almost to 5,000.
Discord if you want to get involved with
dev. We're building the fastest RL, all
open source. We'll all be super simple
and compact by the time it's done. And
you can follow me on X for more RL
content. I'm streaming all day tomorrow
if I'm not back later today. So, thanks
all. I'll see you around.